you're involved in a lawsuit oh yeah and
yeah and so you were at the airport and
you got searched and you're the basis of
the lawsuit is
these guys searched you
because you're black yeah right yeah and
what what happened exactly and what it
was the biggest [__] so I I I'm
filming righteous gemstones with Danny
McBride in in South Carolina
and I have a connecting flight I got to
connect through Atlanta to go back to LA
and then I'm in the Delta Lounge
whatever wait for my flight I go into
the little Jet Bridge and these two
plain closed cops that I didn't know
were cops just like Ambush me as I'm
like walking to the on that little
awkward claustrophobic narrow uh Jet
Bridge to the plane
and they're like hey we have reason to
believe that there's drugs being
transported through this airport are you
carrying drugs do you have marijuana on
you do you have pills on you that aren't
prescribed to you do you have heroin do
you have cocaine like drilling me it's
basically stop and frisk and I'm like no
what are you talking about no no no no
no and then and then they're like do we
have permission to search you and I go
do I have to say yes and the guy was
like God no and uh and then I was like
that was really strange and I got on the
plane I started texting a couple of
friends of mine that are lawyers
they were like that is [__] you
should like tweet to the mayor of
Atlanta or something because I'm in
Atlanta I started tweeting to the mayor
of Atlanta tweeting to the uh Atlanta PD
they're like that's not us that's not us
turns out it's like the neighboring
County Clayton County and they were
doing this whole racial profiling uh
procedure where they would stop like the
majority of the people they stopped were
black and brown people
uh and they would shake them down for
money they would go do you have any
drugs on you and if they did find drugs
they would be like we can either take
you to jail right now or give us all the
cash you have on on you so they were
just shaking black people down for cash
if they found like a vape pen or like
one little nug of weed on them they'd be
like give me all the cash you have on
you and they were they were raking in
tons of money by doing so when I was
reading about this I said Eric's got to
go into court and do the rip away suit
bit where you walk in and just you're
naked in front of the judge I mean just
you gotta you gotta do something
I might lose the case if that's the if
that's the strategy but well for the
strip searches at least when you're
going through the airport you should
have the rip away suit so hey go ahead
yeah
don't worry don't worry officer my
clothes come right off
foreign